I'll just talk about Elon musk's poll
that he did a couple days ago talking
about
whether he should be replaced or not and
the votes came out uh 17.5 million
people voted he said you know out of the
17.5 million 57 percent showed that Elon
should step down as the CEO of Twitter
which this doesn't mean he is no longer
owning Twitter it just means he's
stepping on he'll still be the chairman
of the board he'll still be the owner of
Twitter he'll just have somebody else
operate Twitter and then a bunch of
talks came out so Twitter musk who could
be the next CEO of Twitter Elon musk's
poll this weekend asking followers if he
could step down as Twitter CEO though he
has ignored the results of the vote in
which 57 percent of he has not ignored
he came out and he said I will be
stepping and I'm looking for somebody
there's a bunch of different names that
are popping out right now uh cerium
Krishnan senior director of product at
Twitter a decade ago in 2020 when he was
appointed as general partner of the
influential Tech and crypto investment
firm and recent Horowitz and this year
he was taped uh by musk to be part of
his War Room shaping Twitter into
whatever it is now number two Blake
Masters is another name that's come up
after losing the Arizona senate election
in November Blake Masters apparently
wants to Pivot back into original career
path one of the other guys who helped
run Twitter some of the existing names
uh there's even snoops out there Jared
Kushner a bunch of different guys uh
musk's fixer or his new favorite lawyer
a Mormon and a former Morgan Stanley
wealth manager musk's fixer Jared burkel
helped lock in the deal that allowed his
boss to buy Twitter with billions in
loans with Morgan Stanley the head of
his family office virtual is also the
CEO of neurolink anyways there's a lot
of different names that's coming up
thoughts I I I want to address the tweet
that you put out there yeah because I
thought I thought that was very
interesting you kind of threw your hat
in the ring and you you kind of made a
proposal right there
um what do you think the the most
important qualities of the new Twitter
CEO should be I so first of all here's
what I did say if you're talking about
the tweet that I sent out let me just
read it so I can say exactly what I said
I said uh because he asked he said Lex
Friedman asked out you know uh I'd love
to come and work and you know do what I
can and then he responded and says in
order for you to do that you would have
to put your entire life savings in it
you you have to be all in if you're
doing this he says I'm all in right
anyways we're on a flight uh to Dallas
yesterday or two days ago Addison we had
a special meeting with uh uh some of our
guys at home office a very very big
meeting maybe the biggest meeting of the
year for a couple people
and uh we flew in you know on the way
there we're talking about this as a Tom
I think we can take this company to a
trillion dollar valuation what do you
think we start going back in for we're
having a conversation about Twitter
you're talking Twitter yeah it's me
Mario and Tom and me Mario and Tom and
uh Samuel on the flight and we're going
back and forth on what we would do you
know here's we could do this we could do
that we could do this we could do that
and I said you know what uh the only
person that I'm concerned about this
thing would be Jen and Mario's Like Pat
you got to talk to Jen about this before
you make the decision your wife yeah I
said well even if we took the shop you
know it would be a job because it's a
fight like you know hey would you ever
run for office I would only do this
because I see this as service I don't
see this as money I'm okay financially I
see this as public service because the
world needs Twitter to stay open the way
it is right now that's annoying a lot of
the people from the swamp who have been
manipulating these guys the government
was paying Twitter nearly 3.4 million
dollars the government was paying
Twitter three point I don't know if you
read the Twitter files how much 3.4
million dollars they cut from the
government to say hey move this hey do
this hey do that they bragged about it
in an email to each other okay so I said
uh to Elon a guy asked me questions
saying hey Patrick would you ever take
the job of being a Twitter CEO of
offered I said yes I would accept the
terms Elon Musk has mentioned publicly
with two other requests salary of a
dollar per year a reasonable Equity
incentive beyond my life savings
investment and we would drive Twitter to
a trillion dollar valuation within five
years 100 series oh and I got a bunch of
different commentary uh some DMS some
interesting messages that came out but
no we haven't heard from Elon Musk no I
don't have an interview and play some
people like Pat has an interview I
haven't spoken to Elon I don't have an
interview I have not spoken to anybody
on this team no conversation like this
taking place but I do believe uh uh uh
that this is a job that needs to be ran
by somebody who is reasonable somebody
that can see both sides we were talking
yesterday what skill set is very
important to be c-suite executive is it
more hard skills or is it more soft
skills in a situation like this I think
this is a soft skilled job this is
somebody that's got great soft skills to
be able to work with both sides yet
Scott is a True Believer that is not
going to compromise values and
principles so for this position he has
to weigh out what he values more is it
somebody that understands engineering
more is that who needs to be or is that
the CTO job not the CEO job is it
somebody that's a true believer of
freedom of speech where they're not
going to break you know compromise
values is that the number one value is
it somebody that's good at communicating
messages with both sides that can play
as synergist is it somebody that's not
afraid of being pushed and being
criticized Non-Stop and public
humiliation what what value does this
CEO need to have to do that whatever
value is at the top for him that's who
he's going to hire and I'm willing to
bet Elon knows what five qualities
he's looking for before he decides to
give somebody this job it has to be
somebody that's ran a business before it
has to be somebody that understands how
YouTube elements are working out where
YouTube's given 55 of advertisement to
producers it would have to be someone
that can bring some big podcast names to
be able to put on Twitter spaces which
is really doing well that's a product
that they can do a lot of things for it
has to be somebody that can bring a
Consulting space to experts to get paid
it has to be somebody that understands a
bit of politics and gamesmanship I I
think those are some of the qualities I
would if I'm him but I'm not him it's
not my company I would look at some of
those qualities before I bring somebody
in
with the current climate right now with
everything that's going on in Congress
about Tick Tock right and Adam and
advocate of getting Tick Tock the hell
out of America I agree what do you think
is the upside for Twitter because I
think if you go through the top 10
social media companies number one meta
number two YouTube Google
you go down the list WhatsApp Instagrams
up there Facebook Messenger then you've
got a couple Chinese companies WeChat
tick tock
um
at least according to these numbers as
far as uh what is it monthly active
users Twitter is in top 15 meaning
they're not even in the top 10 right now
uh where do you think Twitter could be
in the next five years
exactly what I think a trillion dollar
company I think Twitter can really
compete with everybody and this can be
the WeChat and many other things but
there's a way he has to go about it you
know look there's certain jobs that are
big jobs but you don't get them because
of just money you have to have the itch
for it certain jobs you will be the most
hated man in America is a job like Trump
was the most hated man in America for a
few years he's no longer by the way I
don't even think Trump's in the top
three most hated man in America today I
think he's number one right now most
hated I think he's number one above
everybody right now I think he's the
most hated man in America he's being
targeted by the swamp he's being
targeted by mainstream media he's being
targeted by the left he's being targeted
by universities he's being targeted by a
lot of different people they can't stand
this guy so now watch this anyone that
takes his job anyone that takes his job
if you can zoom in is what he's saying
to you yeah anyone who takes his job
elon's job will be a modern day I know
this is going to sound weird you're
going to be a Rupert Murdoch type of a
guy wow yeah and and if you know like
who Rupert Murdoch was this guy was
never loved except for people that
worked with them and were part of fox
the guy was hated for ever okay but he
built a 100 200 billion dollar company I
don't know the exact valuation of fox
it's not a job for everyone especially
somebody that
uh uh if you want to be liked this is
the last job you want to take well you
hit the nail on the head with Rupert
Burdock because who did he appoint to be
to run Fox news for Susan multiple no no
he had uh Roger Rogers I'm thinking
you're talking about the current CEO no
no so my point is this with uh you bring
up a good point with the murdochs
because I went and I kind of went and
saw who's running all these companies
with the exception of Zuck right we all
know Mark Zuckerberg is running Facebook
meta
the last thing you want with these major
social media companies are household
names right now everything the spotlight
is on Elon but if you go down the list
here okay so who runs YouTube now Susan
wojinski like no average person does not
know her name I cannot even pronounce
her last name who's the CEO of Instagram
these days obviously Instagram is owned
by Facebook Facebook and meta we know
Zuck but who's the CEO of Instagram
we don't even know his name his name is
Adam Morrissey okay moseri all right
Mark benioff owns time Jeff Bezos owns
wapo you have all these you know whether
it's social media whether it's major
um news outlets it's very low-key I I
actually completely understand why Elon
would you know throw his hat in the ring
bring in literally the kitchen sink but
then step away and then and then assign
somebody to the CEO that isn't going to
make the waves and the headlines here
because ultimately it's not it's about
freedom of speech it's about Free Speech
it's about the First Amendment it isn't
about Elon I think I mean by the way do
you think he abides by these polls like
I think he does obides Bible I mean
meaning like if he does he like he he
reinstated Trump he said should I
reinstate Trump they did it boom so how
much credibility would he lose if he
doesn't abide by no he he you've seen
the last tweet right there yesterday I
will resign I see you as soon as I find
someone foolish enough to take the job
after that I will just run the software
and silver teams meaning I think he's
going to abide by the fact that oh yeah
in that sense yeah I actually think I
actually think he will Tom what are your
thoughts on this oh first of all I think
the world the world is
completely confused by this and to the
ignorant Lemmings that are out there
screaming oh you know he's gonna leave
he's gonna leave he owns the company
people yeah that's like my dad saying
okay I'm not going to be the dad of the
family anymore but I am going to be the
chairman and I still make the most money
and I control where we go on vacations
great but he's not Dad anymore he's
stepping down fantastic
people don't get it he's about to become
chairman and he's going to run the
software teams and all the things that
he's really good at and he's going to
put a CEO in place that has those
qualities that Pat talks about there's
new features have to come out we need to
attract talent to this we need to
attract user base to this you need to be
balanced on the political side of this
that's the job of that new CEO and it's
going to be a thankless job a tough job
for someone who's got the ability to
come in there and do that and then as
you get the users back look it's 400 oh
it's only 14th in the world but it's 400
million users if that doubles to 800
million users I think it's number four
or five in the world so suddenly this
thing is going to be right where we
think it's going to be I believe it's
going to be a trillion dollar company
and what you know Elon Musk is crazy
like a fox and a lot of these critics
are out there just finding something to
do and they're being played baby they're
being played he knows exactly what he's
doing it's yesterday you know it's crazy
yesterday we're having a meeting and
we're thinking about doing something
with LinkedIn how much was the thing
that we want to do with LinkedIn
oh yeah it was a thirty thousand dollars
for like unlimited recruiter access I'm
not asking what it is I'm just saying
how much was it thirty thousand or
thirty thousand dollars yeah so think
about it so LinkedIn has a feature where
you pay thirty thousand dollars right
okay so
I I think Twitter can allow people that
are willing to spend that kind of money
to get access to information that others
are not going to have there's so many
ways to create revenues with this
company you know the the saying goes you
know we're in a church you know first
you bring them into the church you
baptize them later Sometimes some
churches that are small they try to
baptize people first then bring them to
church now hey man just come to the
church and look you know what this place
is kind of fun I like this place we'll
baptize you later okay so Twitter is now
bringing people to the church which is
Twitter you're going to be able to
baptize them later with a product you're
going to be able to baptize people to
say I'm going to spend money on this I'm
going to buy this service I'm going to
do that I'm going to do this and by the
way you realize there's an element of
like these video games Candy Crush and
all these other guys one time I'm in
Colombia with a couple of my friends and
one of my friends is like six hours he's
on the phone like what are you doing
so we're at dinner it's like this I'm
like hey what is he doing he says oh
dude he's so addicted to this game he
spent five thousand dollars yesterday on
the camera what what he says yeah he
bought this he bought that he bought
this how do you think these games are
becoming what
multi multi-billion dollar franchises
because it allows people to gamify you
know how many opportunities there is to
gamify Twitter like you know how many
like imagine if it says you can buy such
and such four hundred dollars you can
buy this for 200 you can buy this for
sixty dollars you can buy that for 700
there's an element of allowing
gamification for people to choose what
kind of money they want to spend and you
would be amazed if people are spending
four million dollars on a land in
cyberspace or meta world just because as
a land is on a beach you don't think
there's some people that would be
spending money on Twitter if you allow
them those types of opportunities where
it gives them a unique you know position
or unique place like how much would it
be well I'll give you perfect idea at
our school think about this when I say
this idea I want you to think about this
so my school okay that kids go to
there's a uh what do you call it auction
okay I'm not going to give all my ideas
I'm just going to get I'm giving some of
them for people to be thinking about
we're at this auction and the number one
parking space for your kid to park and
I'm sitting on like a parking space my
kids are 10 years old nobody driving
yeah okay let me see where this thing
goes to number one parking space where
the kid can park here and walk right
into their classroom they don't have to
walk 10 minutes they will never be late
okay obviously I could care less about
the spot because I don't have my kids
that are 16. and it's like all right
five thousand dollars 5 thousand dollars
is the start this is not going to go
past six thousand dollars
ten oh my fifteen holy [ __ ] 20. 25. 30.
I'm like be quiet 35 000 for the one
parking spot okay let me ask you guys
this crazy question how much is the real
estate worth on Twitter when you log on
to have the 10 people to your left to
follow follow the following people how
much is that real estate worth millions
millions are you freaking kidding me
it's that 10 million box like are you
are you like imagine go to go to your
profile right who to follow you have all
that freaking on the right side what the
hell are you doing wasting that space
let me pay for it well what is all this
[ __ ] suggested stuff for let me pay
for the top 10 spot the number one spot
you know what I would sell the number
one spot for for 30 days how much are
people paying for FTX Arena to have
their logo they're 100 million 200
million dollars for 10 years dude that
say that's a 10 million dollar a year
position to have and some people would
pay for it they would pay for it there
are so many ways for Twitter to make
money there has to be a capitalist that
understands marketing and positioning to
say
here's how we can bring revenues to uh
to Twitter so you're going to need
content creators like a Mr Beast you
need Rogan you need people like that
that are coming on there there has to be
something with those guys you have to
bring humor you have to bring fun you
have to bring the news guys you have to
give the news guy some kind of ranking
credit score there's so many things you
can do to make this the most popular
website in the flipping world but you
need the right person too that's a great
idea this could be a trillion dollar
company so what all the craziness taking
place I believe future looks right if
you believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks right
here future looks bright here we got
them in white we got them in Black we
got them in red are black on black sold
out these are about to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he bought three
then when those three people weren't in
the office they had to order 58 of them
because people wanted the future looks
bright hat especially during times like
this because ain't nobody saying future
looks Pride toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]